welcome to this video playing Grand
Master Dharma Enoch let's see
even Zahra Joe that's a very strong
player to 639 I think this is even an
old raging yes improved since then okay
hmm you know okay let's see what we get
normal Dooku piano yeah this is an
interesting move order aiming for this d
for gambit night at 64 this is not
really great but I don't know how I just
played some I'm playing this avoiding
avoiding the complication let's see if
we get a fairly standard position now -
whoa - isn't there an idea for some it's
some lines my space preventing that
there's also let h5 sometimes it's this
here or I think I play h6 first and now
here so it's an interesting way to play
is Queen f6 and move yeah maybe going to
to inform okay very quick play so I may
be playing really book line without
knowing it too - well however if I
capture what exactly is this point takes
I didn't really understand it takes take
six Knight takes Knight takes Bishop
takes I'm gonna have to of course h5 is
hanging but I'm gonna - isn't this good
hmm it's very suspicious how quickly is
playing all that I wonder if I'm just in
a bad line here and this guy is really
knowing what he's doing
but okay you need to show me how exactly
is going to refute that I can't even
take with the Queen yeah maybe maybe
after Bishop takes I have some
coordination issue this could be but 93
but I can't put night on f4 I don't see
it yet
let's see ya spend a bit bit too much
time maybe that's a typical typical
problem I mean sometimes the stronger
players simply spend more time because
they're aware of some things that might
actually happen to them you seem more
sometimes cost you a bit of time well
sometimes some would recur players I'm
not referring to this guy is super
strong but I mean in this blitz games
you sometimes see people dashing I would
move after move after move well maybe I
could have taken on edge for actually
this would have been interesting very
interesting even bishop age 3 on age 3
not on edge sure okay it's not a bad
position anyway I have won a pawn but
would have been probably very good for
me
but maybe I can actually tonight see
form I don't know
rookie five has an additional idea
Haruki 5 h 5 g 5g 5 getting a look left
on the fifth-ranked going okay he's
trying to drum up some play here mmm an
interesting interesting point in this
game there is also the various ideas
with the sacrifices on h3 for example
again on g2
okay let's see let's do it like that I
need to UM to simply move it cost him
some time those long it's know things
and now 93 was my idea he's got this
check however so I wanted to insert the
sec here I thought this would be
interesting because I'm after the
capture here Queen takes the screen of
two enters this must be bust
really and they've got Queen f4 check so
he cannot really go yeah
does the see can do but now I take it if
he recaptures Queen f2 is just winning
Queen f2 Lukey eight will kill him this
looks like wind really of course you can
always spoil it but it's a totally
winning position he said got a hard time
to remove the screen takes is not
working and I'm just threatening to take
on b3 getting his attacking bishop
exchanged
yeah Bishop esri was surprisingly strong
I wasn't really aware that it is winning
outright it I just thought it looks like
a good solution with a little time on
the clock you're not sure what he should
do here take on c6 maybe hope for the
best
yeah if I take b3 now takes on b7 moon
yeah maybe look so slightly annoying if
I take c6 Quincy one I also have b5
using the pin yeah maybe
looks like a pretty clean solution b5
getting the piece back okay I know he's
in a pin well his owner said ah you
don't have 7 this I shouldn't have
allowed now that was really stupid time
warning integer completely unnecessary
of course now it's in a way interesting
again okay
probably there's still a win but
entirely unnecessary to get this - to
have these problems
okay is threatening to with this
discovered check now moxie it is not
really on checking age seven
[ __ ] sorry this was I really made life
extremely difficult this was really
stupid to take on c6 I just didn't see
95 at all check yeah Bishop g6 big
threat so check
check check
checking cream here Wow
check yeah I'm overstepping the time
check logic forth it's time yeah this is
this is really a tough loss I mean like
completely completely destroying and to
be honest but okay this was a very
stupid idea to take on c6 he has
probably every move wins basically this
is the easiest prolly yeah it's just
minus five yeah I just need to take this
bloody bishop why didn't I do that I
mean it's yeah 95 95 is even a draw
it's not like I can do something here
anymore
check yeah this is losing already yeah
now it's winning again for black but
okay this is it's useless it's just a
very little time for both sides it's
it's it's your chance to look at the
computer here it's a win again Queen e2
wins but you have got 23 seconds
that's a check it's very very tricky
with this load time to play check check
I that's Queen age six know this I could
could maybe try in seven seconds check
yeah but it's no it's perpetual but okay
it's useless the main point is of course
here this is just idiotic but I don't
you take the take the bishop I just need
to take this piece that it's over can
take here recapture and then I just get
get b7 somehow I don't know how Queen c6
or whatever
yeah and it's just resides
I get the porn and that's that's it yeah
the idea is just just a blunder
basically here black is an excellent
shape and maybe maybe here there was
already Bishop a dream not a hundred
percent sure alright seems white is okay
I don't have any attacking pieces I mean
like a rue Kanye this is I went here
yeah d5 is just winning for black
exactly like that it's the it's a
precise computer line leading to a black
win yeah but it doesn't help I just need
to take b3 and I didn't do that alright
thanks for watching